these days billionaire Elon Musk does
much of his communication through
Twitter the company he now owns on
Friday musk appeared in court on the
witness stand in a trial over tweets
that may have crashed the stock price of
Tesla another musk company leaving
shareholders holding the bag
from San Francisco of correspondent John
Blackstone has this story
as a CEO with Rockstar status a builder
of electric cars
and Rockets and now the controversial
owner of Twitter Elon Musk is a hero to
some and a villain to others but it was
as a defendant that he testified Friday
in federal court in San Francisco where
he told the jury just because I tweet
something does not mean people believe
it or act accordingly musk is being sued
by Tesla investors who say they lost
billions when in August 2018 he tweeted
and considering taking Tesla private at
420 dollars funding secured Mark fagal
is a retired Securities litigator this
is an unusually straightforward case you
have a couple of tweets that are as
close to black and white as you as you
can get did he in fact have funding
secured or not so it's much simpler than
the typical Securities fraud case the
investor lawsuit claims musk never did
have funding secure wood and the lawsuit
suggests musk set the price as part of a
joke claiming musk grounded the price up
to 420 per share because he thought his
girlfriend at the time the singer known
as Grimes would find it funny due to the
significance of the number to marijuana
users 420 is a code for marijuana could
he say I was a joke they shouldn't have
taken it seriously they should know that
I that I'm not Dependable when I'm
tweeting I think the flaw in that
argument is it did drive the price way
up so clearly it appears that investors
did take it seriously one of those
investors was Glenn Littleton the first
witness in the case who testified musk's
tweets cost him more than three million
dollars as Tesla's share price soared
and then dropped as it became evident
that musk did not have funding to take
the company private in his opening
statement Tesla's attorney said musk had
simply used the wrong words in his tweet
interestingly his defenses pretty
limited because the court has already
ruled as a matter of law that the tweets
were misleading so he can't come in and
say in fact I did have the money
available to take the company private so
if he doesn't have the ability to say
these tweets weren't fraudulent it
really leaves intent I didn't intend to
mislead the market and he can also argue
that really this didn't impact buyers
you know investors were Investing For
Myriad other reasons and it wasn't my
tweet that caused them to lose money
what are the risks for human testifying
well ultimately this is going to come
down to credibility so like I said we
already know from the court that this
tweet is misleading it's really what was
his intent behind it it will be up to
the nine members of the jury to decide
how much investors were harmed in the 10
days after the Tweet so as a technical
legal matter if you bought during that
period the damages are calculated by
what happened after you bought when the
truth was revealed and when the truth
here was revealed that in fact he was
not going to take the company private
and the stock collapsed that should
really be the cutoff date people were
harmed as of that date but as more and
more cars rolled off the Tesla assembly
line over the next years the stock
backing up the successful car company
remained volatile even hitting historic
highs that can now complicate the legal
dispute over losses the big issue is how
much were investor losses and if you
look at a longer term Tesla's stock
price skyrocketed in the months and
years after these tweets so you could
say well people who were misled by these
tweets and decided to buy Tesla stock
ended up doing okay as a result mosque
and Tesla have already paid 40 million
dollars to the Securities and Exchange
Commission to settle fraud charges over
the tweet
this case could cost musk Millions more
musk has a lot of money though he can
afford to pay his lawyers to take it to
trial he can afford to pay damages most
companies and individuals the potential
Stakes are so high the amount of
investor losses are so high that if you
roll the dice of trial and lose that's
going to put your company out of
business he is the second richest man in
the world he can afford to pay damages
so he's taking a chance not long ago he
was the richest man in the world thanks
to tweeting
musk testified for less than a half hour
Friday he's expected to return to the
stand Monday for CBS Saturday morning
John Blackstone San Francisco
interesting on his face as he said what
a simple case a transparent case it is
he said this it's right there right
another question is what was the intent
and what was he thinking and then it's
also I feel like the good and the bad of
Twitter all in one yep pretty much yeah
anything goes I guess